hey i'm curious um
was there ever a record or any sort of
moment creatively that you guys as a
group regret
looking back on on on your guys's career
i got i'm gonna i'm gonna speak on this
y'all assistant since i had it damn
there everything to do with it
like you know even though now we come
back together
and we talk about that we laugh about it
now but like i gotta say another age
against machine album
you know there's some regretful parts on
there for me man cause i think the
ambition was blind
and man like you know we was in another
spectrum and spear
man like you know an atmosphere around
that time and trying to
correlate you said like core audience
with commercial appeal
you know and so on and so forth and just
trying to try to pull it off and that's
that's me man like you didn't really
like you know i think it was some some
different kind of malfunction
like songs like amy and my very first
white girl and you know people
but you know what you guys have tried
this before in 2013. you know what i'm
saying that i
did i don't know what i'm saying so
check it out so i was like vinnie mom
always been controversial you know
and dangerous he said like you know like
the south's most dangerous
group because i like to you know look at
it so with that
i felt like it it linked itself to
you know a larger conversation but it
was supposed to be shock value
controversy blah blah blah blah blah
but instead of that it just ended up
just being a disconnect
i mean like and disappointment i'm so
like you know because you know
we might even have to we might not have
to reach that far sometimes
sometimes you want to reach to to uh you
know be like
to grab you know uh what you feel like
is yours what you feel is when you're
in your reach but sometimes you stretch
yourself too bad
you know what i mean um and i will say
that i can be honest in saying that in
retrospect
but then there were some moments i think
people also maybe listen back
to that project now especially
especially after we've nailed it with
this project
i think people will uh listen back to
that and be like okay
i can appreciate it more and see it in a
different light
for what they were trying to do in that
time period i'm saying you feel me but
like
the missing link of that album was the
cohesive
uh sonic uh you know sound bad
you know and just the energy you know
and the affection of organized noise i
was gonna say organized noise yeah
yeah yeah if you if you do something by
default and everybody not
not you know you can't have you can't
expect nobody to halfway
support you man like don't never ask
nobody to strive to offense
for you man like never no neutrals with
us man either park or drive
you know what i'm saying right i think
it's safe to say like
the people who are screaming they want a
goodie my album in 2020
are the people who want y'all to work
with organized boys they're the people
who like
they're like yo you know i think that
there's something to be said about i
just listened to i don't know if you
guys heard the new busta rhymes album
um yeah great album right but i i heard
his album and i was like yo
buster did not like busted
he took his time on the album but what
he did was he made an
album that he knew his core die-hard
fans would appreciate in 2020
right and i feel like when i when this
and that album got announced i was just
so excited man
i'm so excited because i if it would
have been announced without organized
mills i'd i would have checked it out
but i was like okay
sonically this is going to be something
cohesive this is going to bring back
you know this is you know and and and
maybe the gift and the curse of the
pandemic you know we're getting a lot of
great music out of this pandemic
hey yo joe mo did i say anything wrong
about that
oh no that one i i mean
i i love i love the age against machine
i mean you know i'm saying to mean
a few songs like you said i mean we
could have
we could have did something else